[Music]
and now it gives me great pleasure to
welcome the 16th president of MIT dr.
Susan Hockfield she will give some
remarks and proceed to introduce our
keynote speaker dr. ray Hammond
president Hockfield
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Nancy
I come to the podium rather humbled by
the extraordinary speakers and the
extraordinary thinkers who have just
gone before me you know we talk a lot
about the future being in the hands of
our students well you've just seen what
the future looked like it looks like and
it's it's very bright
- Rick that was a magnificent
performance you know we all carry the
words of the Reverend dr. Martin Luther
King jr. around in our heads and they
they thread themselves through our
thoughts every day but hearing them
spoken aloud hearing them sung out to us
reawakens their power to hear them
transports us back to riveting time in
American history but hearing them in
this place sung out by a member of this
community
I'm also intensely aware that we are in
the present we're in the present and
this is a remarkable moment for America
- we are in the midst of one of the most
exciting political contests anyone can
remember a contest in which two
candidates with a very serious chance of
winning the presidency of the United
States two candidates are an African
American man and a woman who would have
believed that 15 10 or even five years
ago for those of us raised in the 50s
and 60s and there are a few of us old
people in the room
this is not the America in which we grew
up and thank goodness for that this is a
different day and we savor these
political milestones but the truth is
that when you look beyond the spotlight
of the presidential race we still have a
long way to go before we have a society
that offers every child an equal chance
to blossom or that makes the most of
everyone's talent or that delivers on
the promise that dr. King rightly called
for 45 long years ago we have a long way
to go as a country and we have a long
way to go here at MIT now many MIT
administration's including my own have
made sincere and truly earnest efforts
on this subject yet as a community
despite the intense unrelenting and
committed work of many many people we
have failed we have failed to create the
serious meaningful change that we long
for and I can tell you that is not a
result that is worthy of MIT if this
were any other kind of problem an
engineering problem or a scientific
problem an unsolved problem in
mathematics or a problem with national
defense we would not be satisfied with
well-intentioned but only incremental
progress at MIT and our scholarship and
our teaching we insist on innovation we
demand excellence in everything that we
do we have a spectacular tradition of
solving really daunting real-world
problems and we have no patience with
complacency or with conventional
boundaries if they inhibit our work but
on the question of diversity and include
for faculty students and staff we have
not yet reached these standards of
achievement we've not come close to
making our community what it should be
and to borrow a phrase from dr. King we
cannot be satisfied until we do and I
can tell you I will not be satisfied
until we do it's not enough to say that
we're doing marginally better than our
peers which we are but that's not enough
MIT should be the unquestioned leader
the place that sets the standard for
what can be done we cannot be satisfied
until we're a community that not only
seeks out diverse talents but that truly
embraces and rewards diverse
perspectives because we know that that
will make us stronger
and we cannot be satisfied until to
everyone who earns a place at MIT we are
a community that says not you're lucky
to be here but rather says we are lucky
you've come here four months before the
1963 march on Washington from his cell
and a Birmingham jail dr. King decry the
complacency of a society that indulged
and what he called the strange
irrational notion that there is
something in the very flow of time that
will cure all ills actually he wrote
time itself is neutral human progress
never rolls in on the wheels of
inevitability it comes through the
tireless efforts of those willing to be
co-workers with God without this hard
work time itself becomes an ally of the
forces of social stagnation we must use
time creatively in the knowledge that
time is always ripe to do right it's
clear from our own experience that the
wheels of inevitability will not
carry us to a solution on these
questions I believe MIT needs to commit
itself to unprecedented sustained
concrete action on diversity and
inclusion and I believe that the time to
do that is now we need to do it because
it's an obvious moral imperative we need
to do it because we're educating
students who in a thousand ways will
lead the nation and America will soon be
a place where no one is in the majority
anymore as MIT sociologist an urban
planner is every year D'Souza Briggs
points out interracial bonds of
friendship can serve as precious bridges
that not only connect individuals to
opportunity but that help make our whole
society more resilient and more
effective our students will also lead in
a global community and to do that
successfully they also need the lessons
of diversity the ability to step outside
their own worldview to appreciate other
people's life's experiences to engage
their perspectives and to work together
to weave coherent global answers finally
and perhaps most importantly we need to
make diversity work at MIT because it
will simply make us better at what we do
it will make us broader and deeper as
thinkers it will make us more effective
as collaborators it will make us more
creative as teachers more understanding
as friends and wiser less complacent and
more self-aware as human beings the
obvious truth is that when we listen
only to people who agree with us we
cease to grow fortunately the reverse is
equally true a number of studies tell us
that diverse teams are better at solving
complex problems why is that well
because on homogeneous teams
unquestioned assumptions
remain unquestioned and everyone gets
stuck in the same place we see the
dynamic power of diversity with great
movements through history that the
mixing of cultures and civilizations
produces huge accelerations in thought
and bursts of invention the Silk Road
the Renaissance and America and its best
moments when our ideas are challenged
and amplified from different directions
they get stronger and they get better
and so do we we need to accelerate this
important aspiration for MIT achieving
that respects welcomes achieving a
community that respects welcomes and
supports people from widely different
backgrounds will require leadership it
will require leadership in every school
and department and at every level of the
Institute to develop this broad base of
leadership throughout MIT we're going to
try something that we haven't done
before I will convene a diversity
leadership Congress a group that will
include all 300 or so institutes
academic and administrative leaders the
diversity leadership Congress will give
us a forum to learn from each other and
to reflect reflect on each other's
experiences of MIT it will give us a
chance to learn together from people who
have successfully built a culture of
inclusion in other organizations and
then to think together creatively about
the next steps for MIT from this shared
understanding we will develop goals for
changing the way we operate and we will
come away with a vivid sense that each
of us bears direct responsibility for
creating this kind of change I welcome
ideas from everyone here and anyone in
the MIT community as to what shape this
conference will take I don't have a
fixed idea of what it will look like yet
but I do know what it needs to achieve
it needs to give us the momentum to make
change happen here the work ahead of us
will be hard for certain
but I'm absolutely convinced that it'll
be worth it more than 30 years ago
America had another pioneering candidate
for president congresswoman shirley
Chisholm she once said I don't measure
America by its achievement but by its
potential I hope all of you share my
belief in the potential of MIT and I
hope you also share my conviction that
we can and must continue working
together to accelerate change in this
new effort I take great comfort in
knowing that we are hardly starting from
scratch we are moving in the right
direction last year under the inspired
and inspiring leadership of Bryan Nance
in the admissions office we admitted the
most diverse freshman class in MIT s
history 22% of our newest undergraduates
are members of underrepresented minority
groups and nine point three percent are
African Americans and as we learn from
the Journal of blacks in higher
education in a study of America's top
ranked colleges and universities in 2007
for the first time ever MIT earned the
highest yield for african-american
students that's to say of the
african-american students we admitted to
MIT over 65% decided to enroll here the
the challenge now is to make sure that
we offer those rising talents an
environment where they can do their best
work our theme today is about the
importance of not only recruiting a
diverse student body but as importantly
of nurturing every student's success as
associate dean and director of the
office of minority education dr. Carl
read is increasing our impact in these
areas through programs that Center on an
ethic of care I love that model an ethic
of care it's a beautifully simple notion
that students do best
we provide proof to them that we care
for them and by expecting a great deal
from them in return and by offering very
strong support for them in their work
through laureates and leaders for
example the ome identifies minority
students with graduate school interest
and potential very early in their time
here at MIT and then helps them build
the trajectory of experience and
achievement to carry them through to
their global goals I also want to call
out the work going on in the School of
Architecture and planning we're last
spring Dina delsanto
and dr. Robin Chapman Dean Adel Santos
asked dr. Robin Chapman to serve as the
school's first-ever manager of diversity
recruiting together
Dean Santos and dr. Chapman are
pioneering an aggressive effort to bring
underrepresented talent into the school
to help this new talent thrive and to
step-up education awareness and dialogue
around diversity Dean Stephen Lerman and
assistant dean Christopher Jones are
also ramping up the efforts in the
office of graduate students
after being redesigned in 2004 the MIT
summer research program or MSRP is
beginning to hit its stride last summer
MSRP brought 61 promising juniors and
seniors to our campus of the 33 MSRP
students applying to graduate school 28
applied to MIT 13 were admitted and 11
will join us here in Cambridge next year
based on this success steven is working
to expand the program even further as
for the faculty professor Paula Hammond
is heading up a committee convened by
the Provost for the MIT initiative on
faculty race and diversity
she and her faculty colleagues have
assembled a research team which is well
into its quantitative research and is
now planning the protocol for upcoming
interviews we can expect an extremely
thorough and revealing study when their
work is done and professor Wesley Harris
has just assumed the newly created
position of associate provost for
faculty equity together he and professor
Barbara Liskov will lead mi t--'s new
focus on faculty diversity and gender
issues across the Institute including
the recruitment retention promotion and
career development of minority and women
faculty to all the people whom I've
mentioned and to many many more who are
working very hard on diversity and
inclusion at MIT I say simply thank you
you have made deeply important
contributions to this community and
you've also taught me a great deal
personally I'm enormous ly grateful for
the opportunity to work with you
together on the challenges that lie
ahead for all of us you know at one time
or another all of us here each of us
made a decision to come to MIT we came
here because we recognized in this
one-of-a-kind community qualities and
values that create an extraordinary
environment
for doing the work we love MIT is a
place that goes out of its way to
embrace new ideas and surprising
perspectives it's a place for people who
get excited when you raise the bar and
if you don't do it for them they'll
raise the bar for themselves it's a
place where we embrace a responsibility
to solve real world problems
it's a place in which we're only truly
happy when we're blazing an unexpected
trail this is the MIT that brought us
together this is the MIT that it can
inspire the next generation and this is
the MIT that will make a difference on
the urgent challenge of diversity and
inclusion in our efforts together we
cannot be satisfied until we have made
MIT a place where every young person who
wants to change the world wants to come
and where all of them feel that they
belong thank you all very much
thank you it's now my enormous honor an
extraordinary privilege to introduce
someone with a great deal of experience
creating change against the odds to name
only
three of his roles as a leader in
Greater Boston the reverend dr. ray
Hammond is the founder and senior pastor
of the Bethel African Methodist
Episcopal Church he is also chairman and
co-founder of the Boston's 10-point
Coalition and he also serves as chairman
of the Boston foundation together and
separately dr. Hammond and his wife dr.
Gloria white Hammond are human
connectors human catalysts the kind of
people who are the life-force of our
communities both of the dr. Hammonds
have also been guides and inspirations
to me dr. King wants to find faith is
taking the first step even when you
don't see the whole staircase
dr. Hammonds life beautifully
illustrates the power of that idea over
and over he's had the courage to start
climbing and in his perseverance
creativity and wisdom the rest of us can
find the inspiration to make our own
climbs as well please join me in giving
our warmest welcome to the Reverend dr.
ray Hammond
[Applause]
good morning that's a pretty good start
especially for people who were only half
awake but we've had a good breakfast and
a little coffee so I think we're making
some progress I have been so excited
about being here today with you've been
looking forward to this for many many
many many weeks this is very much a
coming home and I need you to take out
your pen and make a little correction in
your program because and this is no
fault of those who put the program
together I fail to really emphasize that
other I should have but following my
name there should be apostrophe 75 as a
graduate of the first class of HST here
at MIT
so this is very much a homecoming for me
after 33 years I have been back since
then but but since 33 years since being
a student here let me express my thanks
to president Susan Hockfield for hosting
this breakfast and really extending this
invitation through my friend and
colleague Carl Reed to all the members
of the MLK subcommittee for putting
together an extraordinary event this is
a wonderful turnout in attendance
there's so many friends here that if I
start calling names we'll be here all
morning so I won't call anyone's name
other than to say I love all of you and
a shout out and finally I do have to
acknowledge one friend and that's dr.
Thomas Byrne who is the husband of
course of president Hockfield in the
tradition out of which I come he would
be known as the first gentleman and I
didn't know if I would live long enough
to see that at MIT I did have the
pleasure of attending the last night's
dinner to honor five individuals who
really embody that spirit of serving
what the Martin Luther King called the
Beloved Community and to my joy I knew
three of them zina Queen at Cambridge
community activist and fellow member
that community of faith called Saint
Paul AME Church in central square leo
Osgood a member of leader of ome and
Michael fell with whom for a brief
moment I was a fellow student in the
karate class taught by sensei Ron McNair
and for a lifetime
fellow admirers of dr. Ron McNair and my
congratulations also go out to Ali and
to laurleen now after president
Hockfield had noted the difficulty of
this but after her it really gets even
more difficult Jumeirah and quake who
and tariq have really gotten us going
this morning and I sort of feel like
after their brilliant and eloquent
presentations and then president
Hockfield getting up and laying out all
of these wonderful initiatives I really
should just take the offering pronounce
the benediction and let us
but I'm gonna try to add some value to
the morning but I can only do that if
you follow along with me by
participating in what I call the
interactive tradition of the
african-american church it's both a
combination of call and response and you
feel free to respond if what I'm saying
may be hittin some issues or nerves that
you think are important but it's also
interaction with the people that you are
with right so from time to time I want
to ask you to just turn to your neighbor
and say some things to him
right but that means you've got to sort
of break through the New England
traditions so we're going to just
practice that a little bit in the
following way I want you to turn to your
neighbor look at them really look at
them right
so you couldn't even do it without
laughing see
now here's what you do I want you to
turn your neighbor and tell them you
look friendly
all right all right now
tell your neighbor
tell your neighbor I'm confident you've
had your shots
amen all right and then finally tell
them so we can communicate
okay so I want you to turn to your
neighbor and ask them this question
where do we go from here
all right and turn to the other neighbor
and tell them where do we go from here
all right
mindful of the fact that you've got
other things to do this morning I'm
going to promise you what Elizabeth
Taylor promised the fifth of her seventh
husband and that is that I'm not going
to keep you wrong
just long enough to ask you to remember
with me these words we shall overcome we
shall overcome we shall overcome someday
deep in my heart I do believe we shall
overcome someday that was the song of
the 60s it was sung in segregated
schools and on integrated picket lines
it was chanted and sanctified church
pews and on secular bar stools from the
backwoods of mound Bayou Mississippi to
the towering projects of Chicago
Illinois
folks were singing about overcoming some
day the lyrics affirmed a dream for
mothers whispering background music to
the cries of their son kiss babies those
same lyrics confirmed a reality for
mourners singing at the grave sides of
countless individuals mostly black some
white who sacrificed their tears than
their sweat and finally their very blood
to drop died for that dream we shall
overcome someday we're here this morning
to celebrate the life of a man named
Martin Luther King jr. man was born in
Atlanta Georgia on january 15 1929 the
son of Martin Luther King senior a
prominent Baptist pastor and mother
Alberta King a bright young man who
entered Morehouse College at age 15 and
had received his PhD from Boston
University by age 26 a man who could
have chosen a secure and prosperous life
as the pastor of Dexter Avenue Baptist
Church in Montgomery Alabama with the
full assurance that he would succeed his
father as the prestigious pastor of
Ebenezer Baptist Church in Atlanta he
could have led a quiet life of prestige
and financial security as a leading
pastor and local community
or even a college or seminary professor
cloistered in the security of the ivory
tower but what a tired black woman named
Rosa Parks refused to give up her seat
to a white patron on the bus the call
went out for a coordinator and leader
Martin Luther King answered that call
and for the remainder of his life he was
caught up in the task of setting the
captives of American society free he
went on to become the youngest recipient
of the Nobel Peace Prize in 1964 and in
1968 at the young age of 39 while
leading Memphis garbage workers in a
strike for decent wages he was cut down
even those who supported him in words
only or who disagreed with him
ideologically could not deny the pivotal
role he played in bringing
african-americans out of the basement of
American society by his life and
leadership he demonstrated that the
power to bring about change belonged to
all people including those of African
descent that the forces of evil are not
always triumphant and that one need not
become like one's oppressor in the
course of fighting oppression indeed the
importance of Martin Luther King goes
far beyond the gains won for people of
African descent in America he should be
as much remembered for the fact that he
called America and indeed all humankind
to task for failing to live up to its
ideals he should be remembered because
he began with the pursuit of civil
rights moved to the pursuit of human
rights and along the way helped to set
in motion a movement that continues to
bear fruit for people of other colors
women the disabled and oppressed people
around the world his was a life that
made a difference for all people whether
they were sharecroppers struggling for
the right to vote children fighting for
the right to a decent education garbage
workers striking for decent pay African
freedom fighters struggling against
Cologne
realism and apartheid Irish marchers for
equality in dairy or people standing
before the shattered ruins of the Berlin
Wall singing we shall overcome six or
seven years ago I had the opportunity
but the city the city exchange to go to
Belfast Northern Ireland amazing city
what they called the troubles had
wracked that place for decades but it
was a battle that had really been going
on for 800 years one of the most
poignant moments was standing in a
vacant lot with a former IRA met IRA man
named Liam who had decided that he would
trade in his bullets and bombs for a
reconciliation and peace work bringing
together communities that he had
formerly fought against and he said you
know I want to take you to see something
ray and as we went back to his home
which was on one of the lines and across
which Molotov cocktails used to
regularly come we rounded a corner only
to see this huge mural on this wall in
this vacant lot and it was a picture of
Martin Luther King with the words
injustice anywhere is an affront to
justice everywhere
it's fitting and right that we honor his
memory not simply with flowery words and
praise of a leader now dead but in an
honest look at the state of his dream
and the condition of those who are still
living so here we stand at a time three
hundred and eighty seven years after
blacks were first brought to the shores
of America as slaves 231 years after the
founding of the American Republic 145
years after the issuance of the
Emancipation Proclamation 54 years after
landmark ruling Brown versus Board of
Education and 44 years after King
declared I have a dream and the question
we must ask ourselves is where do we go
from here it's a timely question but
there's no doubt in my mind that we're
dr. King alive to see this day in time
he would
be amazed amazed that those shut out of
the economic and political mainstream of
America for centuries blacks and
Hispanics and women having growing
numbers moved into positions of
decision-making in power that were
undreamed-of in his day senators
representatives cabinet secretaries
presidential candidates mayors of major
cities CEOs chairman of Joint Chiefs of
Staff foundation presidents school
superintendents just to name a few he
would be flabbergasted by the thought
that the frontrunners and only
contenders for the Democratic nominee
for president of the United States are a
black man and a white woman don't tell
me that God doesn't have a sense of
humor he'd be amazed that America's
middle class has become integrated to a
degree considered radical and
revolutionary in his day
amazed that students of color have been
admitted to institutions like MIT and
the numbers that they have he would be
amazed by the impact of a movement begun
by himself and a host of freedom
fighters most of whom remain nameless
but I'm also sure that if he were here
he would agree that the most pressing
matter is not simply commemorating his
life no remembering the civil rights
movement but asking ourselves this
question in the face of continuing
challenges on address problems and new
crises where do we go from here
now this is always a ticklish subject
how do we acknowledge the reality of
past and present discrimination and
opportunities and resources without
getting into whips and leather the guilt
game and contest to decide which group
has been more victimized is it possible
to remember and address our history so
that we are not as George Santayana
warned us destined to repeat its
mistakes while not becoming trapped by
that history in a never-ending cycle of
recrimination and
niall where do we go from here that was
the title of the book that Martin Luther
King published in 1967 the year before
his death at the time that he wrote the
book the civil rights movement was at an
important crossroads it was under
pressure from whites who argued that the
gains already realized were sufficient
and that it was unrealistic and
unnecessary for blacks to press any
further claims on the other side were
blacks who argued that the pace of
progress was far too slow and that the
time had come to struggle by any means
necessary
including violence the former accused
king of being too militant and a rabble
rouser the latter accused him of being
too conservative and an uncle tongue
the question was timely then and it's
timely now it's the question that I ask
of myself as a leader in the faith
community in the philanthropic community
every time I recall the statistics
around me it's the question that I'm
forced to confront when I remember the
words of a young drug dealer who became
my mentor as we were confronting
violence on the streets of Boston and
skeptical of the real intentions of the
church he asked me pastor Hammond why
should I be on the bottom of your hustle
when I can be on the top of my own where
do we go from here it's the question
that I raised for this gathering of
elite academics and students this
morning in general and my alma mater MIT
in particular in a globally
interconnected shrinking and
increasingly diverse world where does
the University Research University and
this research university go from here as
the barriers fall and the glass ceilings
are shattered in the private and public
sector where do we go from here
in what many have called the post-civil
rights era what do we really mean when
we talk about ensuring educational
access our opportunity our challenge
where do we go from here now I don't
need to tell you that the debate over
diverse versity remains contentious at
best and divisive or
arising at worst whether we talk about
it under the rubric of affirmative
action multiculturalism transcultural
ISM set-asides of affirmative
opportunity there tends to be much heat
and often little light in discussions
around this subject let's begin by
acknowledging that while there are
certainly people who are racist sexist
or classes there are also many people
who are not captive to any of those isms
and who yet remain troubled by what they
see and hear whenever the discussion or
policy deliberations turn to the subject
of diversity what they see is the
potential for if not the reality of
reverse discrimination that is doing now
to others in the majority what was once
done to those in the minority what they
hear is the lowering of standards
playing fast and loose with competencies
and qualifications for the sake of a
numbers game what they envision is the
nightmare of social engineering
attempting to change human relationships
by law or regulations or policies but is
it reverse discrimination to nurture the
interest of youth and to search for the
best and brightest among people of every
race ethnic background and gender
especially those to whom the world of
science and technology have been an
invisible Kingdom I don't think so is it
a lowering of standards to consider not
only standardized test scores and grades
but recommendations and evidence of
performance in the lab I don't think so
and finally is the quest for diversity
with excellence an example of social
engineering or is it instead the kind of
social engagement that characterizes a
community a nation a profession and a
university at its best
let me quickly suggest three reasons for
strengthening our commitment to ensuring
educational access at every level of the
research university succinctly stated
they are pipeline pedagogy and policy
tell your neighbor pipeline
pedagogy and policy I'll let you in a
little secret black preachers sort of
having a literation thing but I promise
not to rhyme at all in this entire
speech by the middle of the 21st century
it is projected that there will be no
majority population in the America
non-hispanic whites will be 50% or less
of the nation's citizens because of
differences in birth rates and
immigration patterns we are becoming a
more diverse nation day by day that's
true of Boston a fact which is utterly
astounding to me I came to Boston in
1967 from the city of Philadelphia where
people of color ruled the subways I got
on the blue line at Logan Airport
discovered I was the only person of
color on the train and immediately
wondered what planet I had landed on 40
years later there is no racial or ethnic
majority in this city what implications
does all of that have for replenishing
the ranks of Science and Technology what
I know is what I learned from a group of
kids who I was working with in a dropout
program in Detroit in the early 80s and
that is what they see often tells them a
lot about what the universe of their
possibilities is let me be clear no one
should ever suggest that only blacks or
Hispanics or women can or should be the
role models for young blacks Hispanics
for women it does appear however that at
least two things may be true the first
is that the presence advocacy and
decision-making power of minority
members within a professional setting
can help to sensitize that profession to
needs of other minority members the
second is that minority professionals
play a vital though not exclusive role
as mentors and role models in overcoming
one of the major obstacles to recruiting
other minority members to that
profession and that is the pool of
interested available and qualified
minorities
if the recruitment of the best possible
pool for the future of science and
technology is the goal can we afford to
overlook the need to increase diversity
in the ranks of its practitioners I
don't think so
nor is the pipeline the only issue
there's the matter of pedagogy Manos
Singam reports the following and his
wonderful article entitled the canary in
the mind the achievement gap between
black and white students in Phi Delta
Kappa he said one study originated
around 1974 at the University of
California Berkeley and it was the
result of an observation by a
mathematics instructor named Yuri Tri
ceman Trice been noted as had countless
other college instructors the black and
Hispanic students were failing in
introductory mathematics courses in far
greater numbers than were members of any
other ethnic group and with us more
likely to drop out of college
this occurred despite remedial courses
interventions and other efforts aimed
directly at this group Trice been
inquired among his colleagues as to the
possible reasons for this phenomenon and
was given the usual list of suspect
causes black students tended to come
from homes characterized by more poverty
less stability and a lack of emphasis on
education
they went to poorer high schools and
where that's not as well prepared they
lack motivation and so forth but rather
than accept this boilerplate diagnosis
try ceman applied the scientific method
and actually investigated to see if it
was true he found that the black
students at Berkeley came from families
that placed an intense emphasis on
education he discovered that there was
also a wide diversity among them some
came from integrated middle-class
suburban neighborhoods others from
inner-city segregated ones what he then
did was to narrow his investigation to
just two groups blacks and high
achieving ethnic Chinese minority he
discovered that while both blacks and
Chinese socialize with other students in
their group the Chinese also studied
together routinely analyzing lecture
instructors sharing tips and
explanations and strategies for success
they had an enormous li efficient
information network for sharing what
worked and what didn't
if someone made a mistake others quickly
learned of it and did not repeat it
in contrast the black students party
together like the Chinese but then went
their separate ways for studying this
tendency resulted in a much slower pace
of learning as well as the suffering
that comes with having to learn from
mistakes black students typically had no
idea where they stood with respect to
the rest of the class and were usually
surprised by the fact that they received
poor grades despite doing exactly what
they thought was expected of them Trice
Minh then went one step further he
addressed this problem by creating a
workshop for his mathematics students in
these workshops students were formed
into groups and worked on mathematics
problems together discussion and sharing
of information were actively encouraged
and rewarded by this means he sought to
introduce to all of his students not
just those who happen to chance upon
this effective strategy the value of
group epic academic effort and sharing
as a method of achieving academic
success one notable feature of this
experiment was that the working groups
were mixed ethnically and in terms of
prior achievement
the second noteworthy feature was that
the students were given very challenging
problems to work on much harder than the
ones that they would have normally
encountered in the regular course the
ethnically mixed nature of the groups
avoided the perception that this was a
remedial program aimed at blacks while
the explicitly challenging nature of the
problems posed to the students meant
there was no stigma attached failure was
simply due to the difficulty of the
problems not to membership in an ethnic
group that was assumed to be incapable
of achieving academic success in
addition when students did succeed in
solving a problem they experienced a
sense of power at having achieved
mastery of something difficult
what Treisman found was that as a result
of his workshop black students
performance
prove by as much as one letter grade
this is a model now I'm being used by oh
and me in its seminar excel freshman
program it's a model that becomes even
more interesting in the light of the
research that president Hockfield quoted
by Scott page whose mathematical
modeling and case studies demonstrate
that diversity in staffing can produce
organizational strengths it's a model
that suggests we are cheating all of our
students when we fail to work hard at
developing diversity in the research
university finally there's the realm of
policy Social Policy in particular
because scientists are more than the
discoverers of new knowledge and ways to
apply that knowledge they are integral
to the discussion of how and why that
science and technology should be
deployed they should be a part of the
discussion about global warming and how
to weigh the prior and ongoing damage
done by developed countries in Europe
and North America versus the growing
damage being done by developing
countries in Asia Africa and South
America
they should be part of the discussion
about the allocation of scarce
technological resources whether they be
advanced AIDS drugs or funds for
promising areas of research they cannot
be the sole arbiters of such questions
but neither can they abdicate the
responsibility for dealing with these
questions and delegate such matters to
civic and governmental leaders
scientists and engineers must be
educators and debaters and advisors and
sometimes deciders what they cannot be
are monolithic mono or biracial and
unrepresentative guardians of
information and wielders of authority
such a state of affairs is growing to be
as untenable in science and technology
as it is in politics and business
pipeline pedagogy and policy
now I've raised more questions than I
have provided answers but these
questions though difficult are
unavoidable I'm reminded of the story of
two hunters who flew deep into remote
Canada in search of elk
they're pilots saying that they had
bagged 6 L told them that the plane
could only carry four out but the plane
we had last year was exactly like this
one the hunters protested the horsepower
was the same the weather was similar and
we had six elk then hearing this the
pilot reluctantly agreed they loaded up
took off and sure enough there was
insufficient power to climb out of the
valley with all that weight and they
crashed as they stumbled from the
wreckage 100 asked the other if they
knew where they were well I'm not sure
replied the second but I think we're
about two miles from where we crashed
last year
[Applause]
as a society we know very well how to
crash we know how to live in a state of
denial and wait for somebody anybody
else to provide the answers we know how
to tolerate situations of inequity and
to try to put the best face on them as
the way things are or the way that God
intended them to be or the fault of
those not as gifted as ourselves my hope
and prayer is that as a nation which has
gone through a civil war and a civil
rights movement we can make a firm moral
and practical commitment to opening the
doors of opportunity ever wider to a
growing circle of people I am a product
of that opportunity extended an
opportunity seized lured by the prospect
of a program that offered a graduate
school approach to medical education I
became a member of the first class of
the Harvard MiG program in health
sciences and technology it was in that
setting that I got my best exposure to
the rigors of scientific thinking and
research as applied to human physiology
and human disease it was also the venue
in which I was challenged to think about
health economics and health policy and
medical ethics I didn't get a PhD but I
did use the knowledge I gained in the
practice of medicine for more than 15
years more importantly that training and
discipline continues to directly inform
and affect my work in supporting aids
work in West and East Africa as well as
health care reform in Massachusetts
where I've had the privilege of working
on universal health care that training
and discipline informs and affects my
work in Community Safety and youth
violence arenas in which I along with
others continue to push the research
policy and programs that can address not
just high-risk youth the symptoms if you
will but high-risk families which are
the vectors for a variety of societal
and personal diseases including poverty
mental illness unemployment family
breakdown substance abuse and domestic
violence just to name a few
the only thing more dysfunctional than
the families from which many of my youth
come is the dysfunctional bureaucracies
filled with good-hearted people with
good intentions that spend far too much
time mopping up the water on the floor
and far too little time turning off the
tap that's making the sink overflow I've
learned over the years that it's much
easier to mediate between warring gangs
than it is between state bureaucracies
it's my blessing to use my training in
learning how to think in arenas far and
wide many of my classmates and those who
followed including that small number of
students of color have gone on to do
exciting work in science and technology
I'm proud to be a part of that cadre and
now my hope is that that cadre will
increasingly reflect the country and the
world it serves I remain unshakeable in
my conviction that we can go forward as
a learning and learning community and we
can go forward as a nation we really can
go forward if everyone black and white
and Hispanic and Asian and male of
female can become as preoccupied with
their responsibilities toward others as
they are with their rights for
themselves we can make that step forward
if we echo the words of Martin Luther
King who warned many years ago now is
the time to make real the promises of
democracy now is the time to make
justice a reality for all God's children
it would be fatal for the nation and for
this institution to overlook the urgency
of the moment where do we go from here
the choice is ours it's ours choose
whether we remove the yoke of oppression
and become what Martin Luther King
called drum majors for justice it's ours
to choose whether we are paralyzed by
fear or the enormity of the task or are
energized by a faith in God and in one
another where do we go from here it's
ours to choose whether the gifted and
blessed among us are willing to share
their resources with those less bless
hours to choose whether we will simply
be doctors or more powerfully ministers
of healing simply lawyers or more
powerfully ministers of justice and
reconciliation simply business women in
business men or more powerfully
guardians of the earth's resources both
renewable and nonrenewable human and
material hours to choose whether we'll
be politicians and policy makers or more
powerfully public servants who model the
ideals of servant leadership whether we
will be people of integrity and vision
that is broader than the results of the
latest polls or the current thinking
whether we will simply be teachers or
more powerfully educators who impart
learning about life in all of its wonder
and inspire us of another generation we
get to choose whether we will combine
the music of slaves in the 19th century
with the words of freedom marches in the
20th century and sing as we travel
through the 21st century ain't gonna let
nobody turn us around this is the faith
we must take with us as we do our work
each day and as we forge a new vision
for America in the 21st century choosing
this course will take vision it will
take faith it will take hard work but if
as one people black and white and brown
and red and yellow and rich and poor and
male and female and young and old and
immigrant and native-born scientists and
artists engineers and politicians if we
choose this course in faith we shall
really overcome thank you
please join me in thanking dr. ray
Hammond for his heartfelt words
thank you very much you have truly been
inspirational now please join me in
welcoming Provost Rafael Reif who will
now recognize the 2007-2008 Martin
Luther King jr. visiting professors and
visiting scholars Provost Reitz
[Applause]
good morning what what an inspiring
morning we have had so far Reverend dr.
ray hem and thank you very much for
inspiring thoughtful and challenging
speech and and thank you truly for all
you do for our society and may be
established that dr. Martin Luther King
jr. visiting professor program to
enhance and recognize the contributions
of outstanding scholars the program
honors the life and legacy of dr. Martin
Luther King jr. by increasing the
presence of scholars at MIT since the
first appointments in 1995 over 45
visiting professors and scholars have
been appointed dr. Martin Luther King
jr. visiting professors and scholars
enhance their scholarship through
intellectual interactions with MIT peers
and enrich the intellectual life of MIT
with their participation in MIT research
and academic programs they are chosen
for their contributions to their
professions and their potential
contributions to the intellectual life
of MIT the program is open to
individuals of any minority group with
an emphasis on the appointment of
African Americans and from now on this
program will be under the direction of
professor Wesley Harris in his new role
as Susan mentioned this morning of
associate provost for faculty equity let
me now introduce our MIT MLK visiting
professors and scholars this year some
of them are here some of them have other
commitments I will emphasize those who
are here with us this morning let me
apologize in advance for my service
pronouncing some of those names in a
moment let me start with the AG Agana
for mechanical engineering
taraji please
after earning it not you have to stand
up because I'm gonna embarrass you for a
moment after earning his PhD from Howard
University dr. agon offered joined IBM
where his primary focus was in the
development of thermal management for
electronic systems in 99 dr. agon
affraid joined the faculty at the
University of Texas as director of
electronics MEMS and nano electronic
systems packaging Center dr. Jennifer is
a fellow of the American Society of
Mechanical Engineers international and a
fellow of the American Association for
the Advancement of science he has
received numerous awards including the
Howard University and the University of
Colorado Boulder Distinguished Alumni
Awards
Thank You Terrance
among those who are not joining us this
morning due to other commitments are the
daughters embedder hum from mathematics
don't byron from the music and theatre
arts i must say that my office loves the
music of don Byron and I get to hear it
quite frequently at the office Anacostia
from writing and humanistic studies and
Women's and Gender Studies William
Harris from urban studies and planning
and we have here the next one
professor Dale yo Akeem del would you
please stand up
Dale is from the Media Arts and Sciences
program he earned his master's and PhD
in electrical engineering at Michigan
State University
he has taught computer architecture
digital logic and speech processing
courses at Tulane University while
pursuing research in said members of
filtering Theory sound classification
and spatial tracking
prior to joining Tulane he held
positions at Sanders Lockheed Martin and
zenith data system he is researching
technologies that permit the observation
of natural environment thank you
the next two visiting professors are not
here without this morning I need sir
Ramirez material science and engineering
and Dwight Williams nuclear science and
engineering and political science
Security Studies program let me just
move briefly into our MLK visiting
scholars let me start with one name that
I can pronounce comfortably Melissa
Blanco Pirelli music and theater arts
dr. Blanco Pirelli graduated from Brown
University with a double major in music
and international relations after
receiving an MA in communication
management from the University of
Southern California she attended the UC
Riverside campus where she received her
PhD in dance history and theory she
served as adjunct professor in UCLA's
department of world arts and cultures
and she has also been adjunct faculty in
the dance department at Cypress College
dr. Pirelli scholarships and I'm quoting
and they've URIs to demonstrate how
dance and theories of their body provide
new methodologies for inquires into
issues of identity such as nation gender
and racial ization she will be giving a
performance and lecture in April 11th in
a place to be announced Thank You
Melissa
most callers who are not here this
morning I would like to mention Brenda
Dixon go child music and theatre arts
Frank Espinosa also media arts and
science and writing program in Eugene
gasps Newport urban studies and planning
and let me conclude with a scholar who
is here with us this morning
Wilton Virgo from chemistry Walton
dr. Virgo earned his first degree in
chemistry at Princeton University he was
a professional associate at Brookhaven
National Lab and did his graduate
research at Arizona State University at
ASU dr. Virgo was the recipient of
numerous honors and awards he arrived at
MIT in January of six as a postdoctoral
associate and then became a postdoctoral
fellow an MFA scholar his research at
MIT is an establishing new class of
molecular beam spectra Sparky he has
published extensively in the Journal of
physical chemistry and while here he has
developed international collaborations
with researchers in Japan Switzerland
and Egypt Thank You Welton
let me just conclude by congratulating
all our MLK visiting professors and
scholars and by thanking them for
choosing MIT and spend some of the
professional careers to enrich our
community thank you
[Applause]
you